this is a cloud database engineer they
received information from their manager
that the company needs to migrate off
their legacy on Prem Oracle database and
move to an open database alloy DB in
Cloud to save some money alloy DB is
Google's fully managed post grcu
compatible database and our database
engineer is hoping to use duet AI to
help them simplify the migration
this will modernize the company's
infrastructure and enable them to build
generative AI experiences using their
data they are hoping to make quick work
of the schema and code conversion
process to speed up the migration so
they can hit the tight timeline their
Executives requested let's observe this
database engineer as they use duet AI to
simplify the task at hand earlier in the
day our database engineer kicked off the
conversion of the the schema by creating
a new workspace in database migration
service or DMS so now they'll open up
the app schema to check in on how the
conversion is going they can see that
some code was automatically converted by
DMS and is showing no issues with green
check marks but it looks like some other
instances need some attention with
review recommended under the conversion
status they open up one of the instances
to take a closer look they expand the
SQL Editor to dig into the code a bit
our database engineer can see that this
is an instance where duet AI understands
the semantics of this Oracle specific
function Cy State and is recommending a
change for Alloy DB postgress to local
timestamp however our database engineer
knows that system clock is actually the
desired input so they change it manually
to use clock Tim stamp
with an interval of 1 minute they know
that they will have to return to the
schema to manually edit the other
instances that need review however our
database engineer is about to be
surprised and witnessed the magic of
duet Ai and database migration service
they hit the save SQL button to complete
the manual conversion and receive an
amazing popup DUI is asking if they want
to fix the rest of these issues yes
please after just one manual fix du is
able to generalize the solution and
apply it across similar instances our
database engineer is stunned and
Overjoyed a large application might have
thousands of similar statements which
would require manual conversion over a
period of months to complete but with d
aai our database engineer is able to do
this in minutes with all the time saved
they can now finally spend more time
impersonating a banana thanks du AI for
making our database Engineers job
radically easier and more efficient what
will you
[Music]
build